en este vídeo me gustaría hablar un poco
sobre las placas tectónicas placas
tectónicas
tal vez ya lo han escuchado antes o tal
vez ya saben de qué se trata las placas
tectónicas tienen que ver con la
superficie de la tierra la superficie de
la tierra está hecha de un montón de
placas muy rígidas que parece que están
rotas y estas placas se mueven
haciendo que todo lo que se encuentre
sobre ellas también se mueva incluso
continentes así que estamos hablando del
movimiento de esas placas aquí tenemos
una imagen que muestra las placas
actuales observen que aquí tenemos la
placa del pacífico
esta es la placa del pacífico también
tenemos la placa de nasca la placa
sudamericana y también hay una placa
antártica pero si hacemos una proyección
en dos dimensiones de la superficie de
una esfera todo lo que tengamos hasta
abajo y hasta arriba se ve más grande de
lo que es
así que la antártica no es tan grande en
comparación con norteamérica y
sudamérica entonces aquí tenemos la
placa antártica la placa norteamericana
y todas estas placas se mueven entre
ellas eso es lo que representan estas
flechas por ejemplo aquí la placa nazca
y la placa del pacífico se alejan entre
sí formando una nueva tierra y observen
que justo aquí en medio del océano
atlántico la placa africana y la placa
sudamericana se encuentran y se alejan
lo que significa que de alguna manera
otra tierra o mejor dicho otra placa es
creada empujando a estas dos placas
ahora antes de analizar las placas
tectónicas y que veamos más detalles
sobre cómo se crean y algunas de las
teorías del por qué se mueven me
gustaría hablar un poco sobre la
terminología porque muchas veces algunas
personas les llaman placas corticales
pero eso no es del todo correcto para
mostrarles la diferencia me gustaría
explicarles dos formas en las que se
pueden clasificar las capas de la tierra
y después
pensemos en su relación con las placas
tectónicas lo que nos enseñan
tradicionalmente es que existen algunas
rupturas químicas es decir cuando
hablamos de las capas químicas nos
referimos a los constituyentes de las
diferentes capas por ejemplo en este
caso la capa de hasta arriba de la
tierra y que es la más delgada es la
corteza imaginen que esta línea azul es
la corteza
y debajo de ésta se encuentra el manto
todo lo que se encuentra entre la línea
azul y la naranja corresponde al manto
entonces este es el manto y esta es la
corteza todo esto es la corteza y dentro
del manto tenemos al núcleo ahora cuando
hablamos de estas capas químicas podemos
decir que la corteza está hecha de
diferentes elementos y su conformación
es muy diferente a la que tenemos en el
manto que a su vez está hecho de cosas
muy diferentes a las que tenemos en el
núcleo pero observen que no estamos
describiendo las propiedades mecánicas
cuando hablamos de las propiedades
mecánicas propiedades mecánicas
estas propiedades hablan de si algo es
sólido sólido y rígido o caliente y
derretido como el magma así que esto
sería lo más frágil y quebradizo pero si
lo calentamos la roca se derrite un poco
y obtenemos algo como el magma que
también lo podemos ver como algo
deformable o como un plástico sólido
ahora cuando digo plástico no me refiero
al material de las fundas de los
celulares sino más bien hablo de algo
que se puede deformar esta roca se puede
deformar porque está muy caliente e
incluso un poco derretida y por lo tanto
se comporta como un fluido aunque es
mucho más viscoso grueso y se mueve más
lento que un fluido como el agua así que
el magma es un fluido viscoso fluido
viscoso y después tenemos algo más
fluido que es el estado líquido a todo
esto nos referimos cuando hablamos de
las propiedades mecánicas entonces
observen que la corteza es sólida sólida
después el manto tiene algunas partes
sólidas como por ejemplo la parte
superior del manto es sólida y la parte
inferior está hecha de magma es
deformable pero dependiendo de la
profundidad del manto existen diferentes
niveles de fluidez y finalmente en el
núcleo la parte externa es líquida
porque la temperatura es muy alta pero
la parte interna aunque está hecha de lo
mismo y la temperatura es aún más alta
como la presión también es muy alta esta
parte es sólida
por eso las diferencias entre la corteza
y el núcleo no nos dicen mucho sobre si
es sólido magma o líquido solo nos dicen
de qué están hechos pero saber de qué
están hechos nos sirve mucho para las
placas tectónicas porque no solo estamos
hablando de la corteza sino que también
hablamos de la capa externa supongamos
que ampliamos esta parte de la imagen
así podemos ver la corteza esta es la
corteza y después tenemos los mantos
superiores a esto se le conoce como
manto superior manto superior entonces
justo debajo de la corteza
el manto es sólido esta parte es manto
sólido y cuando hablamos de las placas
estamos hablando de las capas sólidas es
decir tanto de la corteza como del manto
sólido a esto se le conoce como listo
litosfera por eso cuando hablamos de las
placas tectónicas no es correcto decir
que son placas corticales porque en
realidad son placas litosféricas
litosféricas
y después de la litosfera tenemos la
parte menos viscosa del manto ya que la
temperatura es muy alta como para que la
roca se derrita pero la presión no es
tan grande como en la parte más baja del
manto donde todo es fluido y viscoso
pero aún así es magma así que aquí
tenemos magma y aunque todavía no
podemos decir que sea líquida por largos
períodos de tiempo cumple con las
propiedades de los fluidos entonces
podemos decir que la litosfera viaja
sobre algo conocido como hazte no esfera
hasta no esfera
así que cuando hablamos de la litosfera
y la aste noosfera en realidad nos
estamos refiriendo a las capas mecánicas
como la capa externa las capas sólidas
la litosfera y la capa que se encuentra
justo debajo de esto conocida como 'las
t noosfera y cuando hablamos de la
corteza
el manto y el núcleo nos referimos a las
propiedades químicas es decir de lo que
están hechas